après quatre vols trois escales et 12
nuits blanches en avion on débarque
enfin à goma qui est la capitale du nord
kivu
et comme il ya une épidémie d'ebola qui
sévit dans le nord de la province
la prise de température est obligatoire
une telle arrivée après avoir réussi à
passer devant une longue file aux
douanes
on plonge dans un chaos routier qui va
nous ferment qu'il de quelques minutes
le dernier ferry pour bouquet vous c'est
donc au lever du jour le lendemain qu'on
découvre le mythique lac kivu est
entouré de volcans et de forêts qui
abrite une faune riche et rare comme des
okapis et les derniers gorilles de
montagne la planète à bukavu on a rendez
vous avec le docteur denis mukwege est
l'homme qui répare les femmes violées le
médecin est sympathique généreux mais
très occupé le lendemain matin notre
tournage avec lui à l'hôpital est
compromis parce qu'il a opéré une bonne
partie de la nuit
alors un tournage avec radio-canada
n'est plus à son agenda route il peut
prendre quinze minutes ce qui lui avait
dit si nous parce que je suis je savais
que j'avais l'interview je les fais oui
je sais et ses textes vous narrer merci
de votre générosité
messieurs me coin j'ai fini par céder à
nos demandes on était vraiment
désespérée alors il nous permet de
filmer une visite qu'il fait auprès de
patientes qui l'a opéré récemment est
vraiment sans cette séquence là on
n'avait pas de reportage
pour atteindre notre prochaine
destination
on longe le lac kivu la route et est en
fait une vraie course à obstacles c'est
difficile de faire un petit kilomètre
sans être arrêté un barrage le premier
est un contrôle et mollahs c'est le seul
où on ne va pas nous réclamer une taxe
quelconque à chaque fois notre facture
kenny qui est un journaliste congolais
doit expliquer que non on ne paiera pas
à chaque fois kenny doit montrer nos
multiples autorisations de tournage donc
à chaque fois on perd 10 15 minutes mais
c'est vraiment le temps qu'il faut pour
éviter de tomber dans le piège de la
corruption rendu au bout de la route de
carrossable devons continuer à moto
notre petit groupe attire l'attention
des villageois alors on doit se dépêcher
d'attaché lors les bagages notre
équipement sur les motos vue puis c'est
l'escaladé 12h à grimper sur une piste
de roches et de sable qui frôle souvent
des ravins vertigineux
alors les vues sont spectaculaires mais
on arrête qu'une seule fois pour prendre
des photos parce qu'on crée la pluie qui
pourrait transformer le sentier en
torrents de boue et tout en haut on
arrive en libye un village mini vraiment
d'une pauvreté extrême
on vit pendant trois jours dans cette
maison de chambres qui craque de partout
le contraste avec le décor qu'on a
quitté le matin est saisissant rhodia
nous accueille dans sa petite maison on
peut enfin un film et après deux jours
de palabres et de pourparlers frustrant
avec chaque fonctionnaire de numbi
chacun réclame un pot de vin qu'on
refuse de payer comme toujours les
responsables des ministères des mines à
numbi veut absolument assister à cette
entrevue l'homme et je m'arrange pour
l'écarter pour que ruggiano peut
s'aborder des vérités que personne ici
n'ose dire ni aujourd'hui quoi jouer le
coup face kyoto note mais kaka ni facile
ni à gérer nos autos cana au jour
[Musique]
pour se rendre au carré mini faut
grimper quelques kilomètres dans les
collines le tournage à la carrière de
coltan se passe très bien mais au retour
on prend le temps de filmer les paysages
majestueux et soudainement on est
entouré de jeune homme agressif on va
comprendre plus tard que nous avons été
pris à partie dans un conflit entre
creuseurs on va s'en sortir avec une
grande frousse et quelques morceaux
d'équipement en moins mais on a réussi à
sauver la caméra et le tournage
l'incident nous force à quitter numbi
plutôt prévu alors on se replie sur goma
le temps de trouver un autre village
mini la route pour se rendre à dubaï est
à peine praticables faire 60 km nous
prend trois heures
on tenait à surmonter tous ces obstacles
pour vous montrer comment les congolais
sont exploités comment des enfants
peuvent mourir pour que nous ici ont pu
jouir de nos téléphones intelligents nos
ordinateurs portables des consoles de
jeux les voitures électriques
et comme le dit si bien le docteur
mukwege et on ne pourra plus dire
maintenant qu'on ne savait pas